people always say to me oh i'm not a
baker i can't bake it's not that it's
difficult it's just once you know kind
of the basics of what's happening when
you're baking it makes the whole process
easier if you can carry on a few rules
they become second in nature once you've
done them a few times here's a few
starter rules to get you going and give
you a little bit more confidence when
you're in the kitchen
like it's still really fun even they
have to follow some rules first things
first read the recipe through i cannot
express this enough you just kind of
want to know what you're getting
yourself into when you're baking and
it'll make baking a much more enjoyable
experience baking is more about
controlling the variables in a recipe
you know baking is all about ratios
pound cake is going to be a little bit
more on the dense side whereas sponge
cake has an entirely different ratio of
fat sugar and flour baking is especially
difficult because of the leaveners that
are in there the difference between
baking soda and baking powder is that
baking powder has baking soda in it but
it also has an acid that reacts to the
baking soda and allows it to kind of
bubble and rise baking soda needs acid
and liquid in order to activate and when
it activates it's going to bubble and
give like a nice
lift to anything that you're cooking
so the temperature of your ingredients
is actually very important for baking it
may seem a little bit like roll your
eyes do they need to be room temperature
if you do have cold eyes that are
straight out of the fridge you forgot to
take them out no big deal it only takes
a few minutes for eggs to come to room
temperature if they're submerged in
water
also when you're cracking eggs you
should crack them on a flat surface not
on the side of a bowl or anything sharp
more often than not this will ensure
that less shell will get into your eggs
butter is the most notorious baking
ingredient that's really annoying if you
forgot to bring it to room temperature
you can actually heat a glass bowl in a
microwave and then turn that over on the
butter and that'll kind of slowly bring
the temperature of the butter up you
still want to have a good amount of
structure it'll be nice and smooth i
mean everyone knows what it's like to
get some nice room temperature butter on
a knife put that on some toast like my
god it's amazing if your butter is too
cold it's just never really going to
blend all that well i write sugar the
easiest way to describe to someone the
differences between white and brown
sugar are probably with chocolate chip
cookies if you're using a lot of white
sugar the cookies will actually spread a
lot more and become really crunchy
whereas if you want kind of a chewier
thicker cookie brown sugar is the way to
go it's got molasses in it has a nice
flavor so that's an easy way to kind of
tell the difference between white sugar
and brown sugar
a lot of american recipes will have you
measuring cups the way that you're
supposed to measure in cups is to spoon
the ingredient into the cup itself so
it's kind of a nice light mixture then
use the end of the spoon to level off
the cup because cups are measured on
volume if you pack the flour in really
tightly then you'll get more flour than
the recipe was intended for which is why
i actually prefer to use recipes that
are weighted and just use a cheap
kitchen scale to measure my ingredients
either way both should get you a good
result one cup of flour is about 125
grams the nice thing here too is that
you can kind of scoop a little bit out
make sure it's totally even and you're
getting a really accurate result every
time
the next thing you want to do before you
start baking is to prep your tin
i'm going to use a little knob of butter
to rub all down the bottom as well as
the sides of the pan this is going to
help brown the cake really nicely it's
also going to help get the cake out when
i'm done baking it so take your
parchment fold it in half then fold it
in half again here we're going to work
on one part and that's going to be the
part where
all the folds meet
fold the parchment in half on a diagonal
and then again one more time on a
diagonal kind of like paper airplane
there you go i'm going to measure the
parchment from the middle of the tin to
the outside
and when i unfold it and it's going to
be a perfect circle that's going to
perfectly fit in my tin
the butter that i put in there before
will help the parchment stick to the pan
and then i'm going to use the rest of
that butter to rub on the parchment just
to ensure that one i'm getting good
color on the bottom of my cake and two
that the parchment will come off easily
when i'm done baking
voila
and i'm going to use a butter knife to
go around and release the sides from the
cake
again you want to use a butter knife not
something sharp just so that we're not
cutting into our tin
the best thing to do is actually go from
side to side and kind of shake it like
that and then because of
the way that we prepped our tin the
parchment should come right off no
problem
one of the most basic recipes for when
you first start baking is a pound cake
and the cool thing about that is that
it's equal parts of sugar butter and
flour and the other ingredients we're
going to need are some eggs we're going
to use vanilla bean because we're fancy
and a bit of salt salt helps enhance the
flavor of whatever you're doing
it helps
sharpen the sweetness if you will all
right so first things first we're going
to cream the sugar and the butter
together now when people are baking for
the first time when they see creaming
the sugar and butter they tend to just
stop midway through you actually want to
do this pretty thoroughly butter and the
sugar are going to be their own leavener
in this way because we're increasing the
volume and beating so much air into the
butter and it's going to help just give
the butter more structure overall as
everyone knows some of the batter will
end up on the side of the bowl it's
always a good idea to scrape down the
bowl
so we're going to continue to go until
we can feel the butter and there's
barely any sugar granules in between
your fingers
i'm just going to go a little bit more
and then one at a time i'm going to add
the eggs
if you add the eggs too quickly you can
actually split the mixture a little bit
because there's only so much moisture
that the sugar and butter can absorb at
once when you see adding them gradually
that's why
so when you're done it should be a
really nice light fluffy beautiful
mixture
everything's incorporated really evenly
it's all a very even color
another thing you see a lot in recipes
is sifting of dry ingredients the reason
why you want to do this is it helps
evenly incorporate the dry ingredients
into the wet ingredients and it also
ensures that if there's any kind of
weird bits or large clumps that it kind
of takes care of those for you flour
that's in so many of our baked goods and
other things has gluten in it so that's
another reason to sift in cakes we want
them to be really nice and light so when
you're folding in or you're mixing in
the flour it's going to be incorporated
into the batter much quicker without
developing too much gluten therefore
having a nicer more
tender crumb our tin is already buttered
with a little bit of flour on there as
well to make sure that it's going to
come out really easily and then just
quickly spread it all out to ensure it's
going to be flat on top
[Music]
it's going into a preheated oven can't
stress enough how much you need to
preheat your oven never open the oven
you want to ensure that the cake is
rising really beautifully every time you
open the oven it's going to slow down
the process so quick glaze for this just
a bit of powdered sugar a little bit of
milk or cream
that's all you need
powdered sugar needs a remarkably
small amount of liquid in order to
become an icing
for decorating we can just do a few
strips of parchment here to lay under
the cake
flip it over
then you just pour that icing over your
cake and here are some sexy shots for
you to look at
because nothing is prettier
than suga
that is so pretty the pound cake doesn't
have any chemical leaveners in it so
it's not going to be as airy as
something like a sponge cake but it's
still really buttery and delicious
[Music]
oh it's so good
[Music]
now on something like brownies
our tried and true tasty recipe uses
melted butter for this one
the melted butter and the sugar is gonna
be combined it's not gonna be light and
fluffy like it was for the cake we're
just kind of combining the sugar and
butter at this point we're gonna add an
egg
another egg
[Music]
so you're just gonna kind of beat until
it changes color like this it's a little
bit lighter more of a batter
then you're going to add that melted
chocolate
you don't have to temper this mixture
because we have so much sugar and butter
in there you're not as concerned about
the hot chocolate scrambling the eggs
and the next we're going to sift our dry
ingredients so i've got the flour the
salt the baking soda and the cocoa
powder we're using baking soda in this
recipe because we're also using cocoa
powder so that's going to react to the
baking soda and be the leavener that we
need to have like these nice chewy
brownies whenever you're folding you
kind of want to cut through the mixture
and
gently pull the bottom up to the top and
that's a really efficient way to mix dry
ingredients into wet very carefully
without developing too much glue so you
want to cut down in the middle of the
mixture scrape the bottom bring it up to
the top and continue that slowly until
you get everything incorporated
brownies are like really nice and
scrumptious but because they have that
baking soda that is reacting to the acid
you don't want to let this sit out for
too long so you want to quickly get it
into your dish
put a few chocolate chunks on top if you
like and then get this in the oven right
away
[Music]
and it's going to slightly rise and give
you nice gooey brownies and let's face
it it's delicious
freshman year of baking what you need to
get through your first few recipes you
know starting with something easy like a
pound cake or brownies will build your
confidence and let you take on something
crazy the good techniques and
fundamentals that you can carry with you
and pretty much any baking recipe that
you encounter there's something that you
struggle with in the kitchen
we'd love to do more tutorials on these
tell us what you want to learn more of
[Music]
something to do with science just comes
out a lot easier maybe physics we have
to do with physics that's why it comes
out easily i don't know
let's go with physics physics physics is
why it comes out
i know a lot about science that's why
i'm so good at this that was a joke
america in the world